all right Tammy's on the line in Dayton
Ohio hi Tammy how are you hi Dave I'm
doing great thank you for taking the
call
sure tell me what's up um well actually
I should say thank you for taking my
call again I called you on January 15th
two beers into a pity party from the bar
after losing my job of 16 years and it
was quite a shock I had 12 little over
$12,000 in baby steps to that I was
trying to get rid of I'm trying to start
a side job and being single there was no
income to rely on and you were so
encouraging and so positive and because
I had been following your plan and I had
my budget I knew where I could cut when
you said go to beans and it might be the
rice and because I had a little my
emergency fund and I had my severance
income I I didn't have to panic I didn't
have to take the hour and a half
commutes with the cake Hut on top of it
down into downtown Cincinnati that I
hate driving in ten weeks after I was
laid off thanks to your program and your
encouragement and the encouragement of
my friends and family they're amazing
without borrowing another cent I got
another job that was April fourth one
seven weeks into it my last severance
check was just about a week ago and
because I had stashed all that money
from being able to cut my budget and
being able to do beans and rice I have
now paid off baby step 2 yeah so are you
making - are you making more than you
used to make man I am NOT I took a
$5,000 pay cut that when I interviewed
for the job was a $13,000 pay cut and I
thought you know what I know if I can
get into this job soon I can use all
this money that I've stashed and pay off
my debt so it'll be like a pay raise and
it'll make up that difference so so I
can take a chance on this job in between
when I interviewed and when they offered
me the job they decided that my skillset
was worth more so they offer
me an additional $8,000 in the actual
offer so yeah I'm only it's only a
$5,000 pay cut from where I was and I
love the job and I love the people I'm
working with and and you'll probably
probably be up $5,000 another year and a
half yeah exactly exactly you are all
set I thought I still got my my mortgage
on my house and and the improvements
that I had to make to get I've got a
business working with horses and I
needed to put in fencing and stuff like
that so I've got a little bit there but
this is the first time I'm 46 I'll be 47
next month and this is the first time
since college that I have had no credit
card debt and no car payment I mean I
did the car I did the car a few years
ago I tried to do one car and bought the
other one for cash and it's a 2004
Saturn and it's got 160,000 miles on it
but it's running great that gets me back
and forth I'm fine with that yeah yeah
it was pretty incredible and I just
wanted to give you an update and say
thank you for your program and I'm
planning on passing on this is knowledge
I've got a couple people in mind right
now and I appreciate it well thank you
thank you for the update you confirm
people often hear me tell someone
something like I told you apparently um
but now you're the proof of it because I
tell people all the time listen if you
go get another job and they're still
giving you severance it's like getting a
signing bonus so getting laid off
getting laid off actually turns into
like a good story and yours has turned
into a great story yeah it was awesome
lie but because of of the budget it was
easy to go okay well I'm not going to be
needing this much money here and I'm not
going to be so it was actually extra not
only what I would have paid towards
those team of those monthly payments but
everything else on top of it and it just
like that I'm making that last payment
this past week to completely pay off all
my cards was amazing I'm so proud of you
you're a hero way to go thank you Dave
very well done thanks for calling in and
sharing that that encourages other
people yeah you get laid off folks that
could be the best day of your life most
people don't think that way most people
don't think that way very well could be
the best day of your life if you sit
around and act like it's the worst day
of your life I can pretty much guarantee
you're going to ensure
to occurred self-fulfilling prophecy but
you know you could be going thank God
I'm finally free of those people and
they're giving me money to leave and I
get to go over here and find some people
I actually like in a better job in an
upside and that's exactly what Tammy did
and she put money in her pocket in the
process it's a good day it's a good day
it's a day to celebrate it is a matter
of how you look at these things
sometimes and Tammy chose to look at the
glass as being half full it's really not
fake optimism or weird positive thinking
it's just a way of looking at things
that is as accurate as the spirit of
Eeyore you don't want the spirit of
Eeyore you want the other one you want
to do it the way Tammy did it way to go
rock star hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you